قررت بريطانيا حضر استخدام تطبيق تيك توك
الصيني على الهواتف الرسميه للوزراء
وموظفي الدوله وذلك لاسباب امنيه على حد
قولها وكانت الولايات المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي وكندا حضرت التطبيق في هواتف
مسؤولها لاسباب امنيه ايضا وهو ما نفته
الشركه المالكه للتطبيق وبيجين التي اتهمت
واشنطن بالفشل في اثبات ان التيك توك يهدد
امنها القومي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي السياقات التي
تعبر فيها لندن و واشنطن عن مخاوفهما من
منصه تيك توك وما طبيعه هذه المخاوف وعلى
اي نحو استقبلت هذا الجن كذلك ما مدى
نجاعه الوسائل التي لجا اليها الجانبان
الامريكي والبريطاني لمحاصره التيك توك
وما هي الاوراق التي تملكها الصين في
مواجهه هذه الوسائل واخيرا ما هي افاق هذه
المواجهه التكنولوجيه التي تاخذها بيجين
مع لندن وواشنطن في سياق صراع تيك توك
وكيف يمكن ان تنعكس على التوتر الراهن بين
الصين والغرب
[موسيقى]
بعد الولايات المتحده وكندا والمفوضيه
والبرلمان الاوروبيين قررت بريطانيا يوم
الخميس حضر استخدام تطبيق تيك توك الصيني
لمقاطع الفيديو القصيره على هواتف الوزراء
والمسؤولين الحكوميين لندن التي قالت ان
الحضره سيطبق بشكل فوري عزت القرار لاسباب
وصفتها بانها امنيه واكدت انه اجراء
احترازي اتخذ بعد مراجعه قام بها المركز
الوطني البريطاني للامن السيبراني وانه
استجابه متناسبه على خطر محدد مع الاجهزه
الحكوميه بحسب قولها
قرار لندن حضر استخدام تطبيق تيك توك على
هواتفي مسؤوليها الحكوميين جاء بوعيدا
انتقادات وجهتها بيجين لواشنطن بشان خطوات
مماثله اتخذتها في وقت سابق تجاه تيك توك
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الصينيه قال ان
الولايات المتحده فشلت حتى الان في تقديم
دليل يثبت تعريض التطبيق الامن القومي
للخطر وان عليها التوقف عن نشر ما سماها
معلومات خاطئه فيما يتعلق بامن البيانات
وتوفير بيئه اعمال مفتوحه وعادله للشركات
في جميع انحاء العالم
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معناها الدكتور اد
ورد جوزيف وهو الساده العلاقه الدوليه في
جامعه جونز هوبكنز ومن بيجينا الدكتور دين
لونج استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه
الدراسات الدوليه في شنغهاي ومن باريس
الصحفي محمد علي السويسي المختص في
الاتصال الرقمي وامن المعلومات اهلا بكم
جميعا فيما وراء الخبر وابدا معك دكتور
ادويه اذا
بريطانيا الان تنضم الى الولايات المتحده
الى المفوضيه والاتحاد الاوروبي وكندا
بدون حيثيات ايضا ما هو السياق الذي
تاتي فيه هذه الخطوات المتلاحقه
في سياق ان
التكنولوجيا الصينيه تشكل تهديدا
للمجتمعات الغربيه الديمقراطيه المنفتحه
هي تشكل تهديدا بالطبع تيك توك مملوكه
للقطاع الخاص
لكنها تدار من قبل الشركه من
وهي هذه مصدر خطر وقلق بسبب التاثير الذي
للحكومه الصينيه على هذه المؤسسه التجاريه
وتاتي
تاتي البخاوف عبر نوعين اولا هذه الشركات
تتقاسم البيانات مع الحكومه الصينيه وايضا
توقعات المنصه
واستخدامها لاغراض دعائيه مثل ما نراه
الان طبعا منصات التواصل الاجتماعي فيها
هشاشه وضعف من
الناحيه لو ان تيك توك كانت في مقرها في
المملكه المتحده لما كان هذا سيكون مصدر
قلق لكنه موجود مقرها موجود في الصين وهي
تشكل خطرا على الولايات المتحده
وانجلترا وبقيه الحلفاء اذا هذا هو
السياق الغربي لاتخاذ هذه الخطوات والذي
استمعنا اليه من اكثر من مصدر ماذا عن
الموقف الصيني والقراءه الصينيه لسياق هذه
الخطوات المتلاحقه ضد تيك توك
يعني تريد ان تفرد
وحظر شركه
هي شركه
تمتلك مين منصه تيك توك
لانها تيك توك خليه يعني
تملك حصه حصه الاسد في السوق التواصل
الاجتماعي بالولايات المتحده وهذا اثار
مخاوف الولايات المتحده ان تسيطر هذه
الشركه يعني
في
حصص الاكبر في السوق الامريكي
مما يهدد
[موسيقى]
والتي تعتمد عليها امريكا وغيرها من دول
الغرب وبين
التهرب من المنافسه الشريفه كما تقول
الصين كيف ترى انتسيا
السياق وسياق مختلف يعني عندما نتحدث عن
التيك توك نتحدث عن وسيله التواصل
الاجتماعي لديها تاثير كبير التاثير اكبر
حتى من حجم هذه التطبيق واكبر من حجم هذه
الشركه الاتهامات متعدده
بالتجسس والاتيامات متعدده بالتنصت ونقل
المعطيات الشخصيه للمستعمل الامريكي الى
الصين رغم كل ضمانات التي حاولت ان تقدمها
الى الجانب الامريكي رغم ان فتحت حتى
الخوارزميات
للتفقد للتثبت من ان تيك توك تعمل بشكل
سليم في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه الا
ان الجانب الغربي مصر على قطع العلاقات مع
هذه
التطبيق
وبالطبع منعها في الدول الغربيه بالمناسبه
تيك توك لديه حضور في الاتحاد الاوروبي
الجزء الخاص بالسلامه موجود في ايرلندا لا
اظن ان مشكله عدم تجرب تيك توك هي السبب
الاساسي ولكن السبب الاساسي هو غموض كبير
بالنسبه لطريقه التعامل مع التيك توك ثبتت
العديد من التجاوزات بالنسبه لهذه المنصه
وثبتت العديد من الاخلالات منها حتى تجسس
على صحافيين منها قرارات باخذها موظفون في
تيك توك يعني هناك يعني طريقه للتحكم في
هذه التطبيقة غير واضحه مقارنه بما نلاحظه
اليوم بالنسبه لبقيه التطبيقات الاخرى
والنظام الاخرى او غيرها من الشركات اظن
ان الجنب التقني هنا جلب مهم جدا لكن
الجانب السياسي يلعب دور مهم ايضا بالنسبه
لهذه القضيه تيك توك شبيه في قضيته بقضيه
هواوي عندما قررت الاداره الامريكيه منع
هواوي ومنع
التعامل ثم بدات في الضغط على الدول
الاوروبيه لالغاء الصفقات مع هواوي وهذا
هو الذي تفعله اليوم مع تيك توك بالنسبه
لدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وبريطانيا على
الاقل طيب يعني واضح ان هذه مخاوف كما قلت
محمد علي السويسي انها يعني لها اساس على
الاقل تقنيا
والدكتور دينغ هذا ما تقوله كثير من الدول
الغربيه والرغم انها لا تقدم دليل واضح
يثبت ان اي اختراق قد وقع بالفعل ولكن
السؤال ما الذي فعلته بيجيني لتحتوي هذه
المخاوف
تفضل
قضيه تيك توك غير ان يعني لم تقدم هذه
الدول تلاهي تلائق
فهذا دليل على انه لا توجد يعني
تجاوزات
من قبل تيك توك وايضا
ساعد شركه تيك توك
وحكومه الصينيه ان يكونوا هناك حلول جديله
شركه تيك توك
يعني
بدات في مشروع تكساس ما يسمى بمشروعتكساس
يعني سوف يتم
تحويل شركه تيك توك الى يعني
منصه امريكيه
وسوف تتم
تخزين كل المعلومات
التي تحصل عليها
في ولايه تكساس بالولايات المتحده وهذا
المخاوف
الامريكيه والبريطانيه بشان
تجاوزات
تيك توك
وبما يتعلق بالامن السيبرانيين الذي يتم
اطارتها من قبل تطبيق تيك توك
لماذا لا يعد هذا كافيا للولايات المتحده
والدول الغربيه الاخرى والسؤال الذي يطرح
نفسه ليس من حق الصين ان يكون لها تطبيق
ناجح مثل تيك توك تنافس فيه
تطبيقات اخرى غربيه موجوده في الصين
وغيرها من الدول
دعني اتعامل مع الشق الثاني من سؤالك اولا
بالطبع بامكاني الصين ان تتنافس على
الصعيد التجاري من خلال تطبيقاتها لكن
السؤال يبقى هو طبيعه هذه المنافسه في
حاله الصين في الولايات المتحده وفي
اوروبا الغربيه لديك شركات خاصه وهي ليست
مسؤوله عن عملياتها امام الحكومه
الامريكيه او الحكومات الغربيه الاوروبيه
وهناك اجراءات قانونيه تنظيميه تنظم عملها
وليس هناك مثل هذا هذه الطاعه العمياء
للحكومه كما هو الحال مع الصين هذان
نظامان مختلفان ومن الحماقه بمكان التظاهر
ان هذين النظامين يمكن الموائمه بينهما ما
بين
الصين والغرب لان النظام التجاري في
القطاع الخاص في الصين يعملوا بشكل مختلف
النظام السياسي الصيني نظام ديكتاتوري
خاضع لحكم الفرد وهم ايضا يتهمون
الولايات المتحده لان تفعل ذلك حمايه
للشركات الامريكيه من المنافسه التجاريه
هذا ليس صحيحا طبعا شركات مثل جوجل وغيرها
تنشط في الصين ولا ارى بان الدافع هنا
التجاري لكن هذا دافع امني تشاركنا فيه
المملكه المتحده والسؤال هو هل من خلال
جعل الشركه الامريكيه الفرعيه كما قال
الضيف فرع مستقل لست واضحا
كانك تلمح دكتور الى ان الحل يكمن في
تغيير النظام الصيني هل هذا ما تلمح
اليه
ليس هناك ما المح اليه وكل مشاهديكم
يعرفون ما اتحدث عنه لا يوجد ما نلمح اليه
انظروا النظام الصيني يعني انت تريد انت
تعتقد ان ان حل مشكله تيك توك وما يحدث
الان هو موضوع انه يتغير النظام الصيني
على العموم اسمح لي فقط ان نتوقف عند حلول
اخرى
نقلتها صحيفه
عما سمتها مصادر مطلعه هذه الحلول تقول ان
لجنه الاستثمار الاجنبي في الولايات
المتحده طالبت الشركه المالكه لتطبيق تيك
توك ببيع حصص ملاكها الصينيين وذلك تحت
طائله حظر التطبيق واضافت الصحيفه ان تيك
توك ردت بان البيع القسري لن يعالج
المخاطر الامنيه وتعهدت في المقابل للتحلي
بالشفافيه وبمر اعاه المخاوف الامريكيه
بانفاق مليار ونصف المليار دولار على
برنامج لحمايه بيانات المستخدمين
الامريكيين اضافه الى منح شركه اوركل كوب
الامريكيه امكانيه الاطلاع على برمجيات
التطبيق
اذا اعود لك
السيد محمد علي السويسي يعني ما بين مطرحه
والدكتور
ان الحل يكمن في تغيير النظام الصيني
برمته وبين ما نقلته
ما مدى واقعيه هذه الحلول المطروحه برايك
بيع الفرع الصيني بالنسبه للفرع الامريكي
بالنسبه لتيك توك هذه الفرضيه طرحت بقوه
في اخر عهده دونالد ترامب وكما هناك توجه
الى ان تشتري شركه مايكروسوفت وشركات اخرى
الفرع الامريكي وتحدثت الاخبار حينها على
تقدم المفاوضات ثم توقفت عندما يعني الصين
وضعت نقطه نهائيه لهذه الصفقه اليوم يرجع
من جديد الحديث على هذه الصفقه وهذه
الخطوه بطلب امريكي رسمي يعني هذه المره
نتحدث عن طلب امريكي للتخلي عن الفرع
الامريكيه فيما تحدثت عنه منذ قليل فيما
يخص تفقد الخوارزميات تقوم به شركه اوراكل
بالطبع منذ مده طويله ثم عندما نتحدث عن
تيك توك وحضوره في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تيك توك تحدث منذ زمن طويل على
نيته ان ينفق وان يكون هناك برامج بالنسبه
للتعاطي مع المعطيات الشخصيه كل هذه
الضمانات يقدمها تيك توك منذ سنوات ليست
ضمانات قدمها اليوم هي ليست ضمنه جديده
لكن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لديها
نظره اخرى بالنسبه لهذه
المنصه واظن ان الجانب السياسي او الغطاء
السياسي يسيطر بشكل كلي على هذا على هذا
الموضوع نظرا لتوتر العلاقات بين الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والصين والتاثير يصل
الى الميدان التكنولوجي كما قلت منذ قليل
ايضا الحديث ليس فقط على التيك توك بل
العديد من الخطوات الاخرى فيما يخص
التعامل مع التكنولوجيات مثل الضغط على
شركات الامريكيه لمغادره الصين
وتركيب الهواتف الذكيه في دول اخرى مثل
الهند مثلا هناك العديد من النقاط نقاط
ضغط تضعها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
بعض الاحيان تعطي بعض الحلول وهذه الحلول
اظن انها لن تجدي ولن تعطي الحل الن هائي
ولا تحل المشكله في المستقبل
في غياب الثقه بين الغرب وعلى راس
الولايات المتحده والصين وكما ذكرت انت
يعني مع وجود هذا النظام عدم امكانيه ربما
التوصل الى حل مرضي لهذه القضيه تحديدا
الى اين ترى انت
امكانيه تطور هذا الصراع في ظل الظروف
الحاليه
سارد على هذا السؤال لكن سؤالك السابق حول
تغيير النظام هذا مهم جدا يجب ان اتعامل
مع ذلك بشكل مناسب الامر لا يتطلب اي
مفاوضات بين الولايات المتحده والصين او
الصين والمملكه المتحده كل من هذه البلدان
هو بلد له سيادته الصين المملكه المتحده
وكل بلد يمكن ان يقرر كيف ينظم عمليات
شركات التواصل الاجتماعي داخل حدود كما
تفعل الصين مع جوجل وفيسبوك التي تعرف اسم
متى الان عليها ان تمتثل للقوانين الصينيه
تيك توك عليها ان تمتثل للقوانين
الامريكيه ليس هناك اي شيء غريب في كل هذا
كلها بلدان ذات سياده اما ما تعلق بتغيير
النظام لا ادري من اين جاء هذا الى الحديث
انا كنت يقول ان كل مشاهديكم يعرفون انا
لدى الصين نظام سياسي مختلف عن الراتب
المتحده نظام مغلق اذا ما اردت ان تمارس
اي عمل تجاري في الصين عليك ان تكون حذرا
كل مشاهدين فيهم يعرفوا ان اكثر من مليون
من المسلمين
هم يعانون من انتهاك حقوقهم ويتعرضون
لاباده حسب تعريفهم انا اسالكم تخيلوا لو
ان ايجار من الصينيين المسلمين هم بسبب
انتمائهم الديني فقط ان هذا الايجار يذهب
الى
يعرض فيديو يقول حقوق الانسان تنتهك لانني
انا مسلم اتخيل انه تيك توك ادخلتنا في
موضوع اخر ماذا يحتاج لحلقه النقاشيه اخرى
ولكن اريد ان اعود لصلب الموضوع دكتور دين
لونج والسؤال عن اور
للرد على مثل هذه الخطوات التي اتخذتها
دول غربيه تفضل
بسر على سماحه
[موسيقى]
لا تزال تملك يعني
اوراق كثيره لانه
مستخدمين هم لدينا يقررون وايضا سوق هي
تقرر وليس الاداره الامريكيه لان تيك توك
يعني
اصبحت
منصه التطبيق التواصل الاجتماعي
المحبه لدى الشعب الامريكي
شباب
هي الميزه يمكن تستدل منها شركه تيك توك
وبعد ذلك يعني نعم
[موسيقى]
الحلقه شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور دينغ لونج
وشكرا جزيلا للدكتور
ادوج جوزيف
لضيفنا ايضا محمد علي السويسي وشكرا لكم
مشاهدينا على متابعه هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر لماذا
[موسيقى]